okay i appreciate it thank you very much
thank you
the congregation will be seated thank
you very much i i know it's a hey we're
champions we want the super bowl here in
l.a right
brought the city together don't you
think i mean we had a parade with dozens
of people showed up and
the game itself
it was exciting to see oh and that
moment after the game when one of the
rams players taylor wrap i think is his
name he's a safety he proposed to his
girlfriend right there on the field
and then the uh the owners find him for
taking a knee so it
kind of ruined the whole
but hey
i read this today i hope this is true
california the first state now to
declare that we are at the endemic
stage of the
corona thing
i'm not sure what that means it has end
in it
endemic yeah the endemics i think it's
kind of like marriage uh you live with
it but you ignore it that that's
endemic
i
i kid marriage
oh
speaking of midlife crises um
where do you see where i'm going with
this
there was a german freighter uh that is
on fire in the south atlantic and
sinking
the bit you know what it has on board
1100 porsches
that are going to fall to the bottom of
the ocean so if you're out this weekend
and you see a douchebag give them a hug
and
speaking
i'm the king of blends
speaking of douchebags donald
[Laughter]
donald trump and his son and ivanka they
are all or ordered this week by a judge
in new york to sit for depositions
and because of their
tax
shenanigans with their company trump had
a habit of undervaluing his properties
for tax reasons and i don't think his
defense is going to fly he said i was
just being humble
right that's not going to work with him
uh oh and the other republican who had a
tough time in court this week sarah
palin
she
she lost her she had a defamation case
against the new york times uh they had a
trial she made some good points but at
the end of the day the jury just
couldn't be convinced that she had read
a newspaper
so that didn't go wrong
and the republicans have a big uh
controversy down in florida they have a
bill there that they're trying to pass
they call it the don't say gay bill
don't say gay they
they don't
really this is what they want to do in
schools they want to make it
verboten to talk to the kids about lgbt
issues if they're like not age
appropriate in their view but come on
this is florida
florida we teach our kids about sex the
old-fashioned way by [ __ ] the teacher
in the car
i kid florida
i love florida
i'm going to you know that i'm doing a
new hbo special right here on this
network a stand-up special it's in miami
we're taping it march 4th and 5th don't
be late
tickets are still available i think are
they i hope
the jackie gleason theater anyway it's
going to be [ __ ] amazing and then
i'll get canceled but it's going to be a
great show
while it lasts
you